[Musique]
Tommy hungerer est sans doute l'Alsacien
le plus célèbre au monde ses livres pour
enfants dont il est l'auteur complet
textes et dessins sont traduits dans
toutes les langues et notamment en
français puisque le plus souvent il les
conçoit en anglais le dernier dans entre
eux Otto vient de paraître à l'école des
loisirs c'est une histoire magnifique et
tendre qui offrira aux jeunes lecteurs
de l'émotion et l'occasion de réfléchir
Otto c'est l'autobiographie d'un ours
enempeluche j'ai compris que j'étais
vieux confitil quand je me suis retrouvé
dans la vitrine d'un antiire et AUAU de
ce souvenir fabriqué en Allemagne il est
offert comme cadeau d'anniversaire à un
petit garçon prénommé David en jouant on
lui renverse une bouteille d'encre
violette sur la F
toute sa vie il en portera la trace et
puis vient la période nazi l'étoile
jaune la guerre les bombardements o
passe entre les mains d'un soldat
américain qu'il sauve de la mort on fait
de lui un héros et au terme de cette
existence symbolique pétrie de
rebondissement il finira par revenir à
son premier maître David et par écrire
cette
[Musique]
histoire